what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to another episode of
beyond omega level where we discuss the
most powerful characters and comics and
for this week's episode we're talking
about a character that has been a major
part of both asgardian and comic battles
as well as somebody you guys have been
asking for in the comments non-stop for
months beta ray bill so beta rebuild was
created by walt simonsen during his
classic run writing and drawing thor and
his first appearance was in the mighty
thor number 337 in 1983. now simonson
has stated that the idea to create a
character that could live up to the
inscription on thor's hammer mjolnir
which states that whoever possesses the
hammer should they be worthy would
possess the power of thor was the most
significant aspect of creating beta ray
bill because up to that point no one but
thor himself had been worthy to lift
mjolnir so simonson wanted to create a
noble warrior that would be able to and
hence vader ray bill was created now
bill belongs to a race of aliens known
as the corbinites whose galaxy was
destroyed by surter resulting in nearly
every corbinite being killed now bill
was chosen to be the protector of the
remaining corbinites which meant that he
had to undergo a process that
essentially turned him into a cyborg and
also drastically altered his appearance
so that he looked more like a horse now
bill is placed in stasis aboard the
ship's scuttlebutt until he's awakened
by an alarm warning of an impending
threat which happens to be thor who just
so happens to carry the same magical
energy that destroyed corbin as both he
and sirder are of asgard now bill is
then summoned by odin to asgard and
after he shows his ability to lift
mjolnir odin orders thor and his horse i
mean beta ray bill my bad to battle to
decide the rightful owner of the hammer
now thor and bill incapacitate each
other but bill recovers first due to his
acclimation to warm climates since the
battle took place in a fiery region
known as scarthen so he's basically
declared the winner now instead of
getting ownership of mjolnir as promised
odin has a new hammer commissioned for
bill called stormbreaker and so bill
agrees to help the asgardians defeat
certain forces and he's basically been a
frequent ally of thor's ever since and
he also shows up quite often to fight
some of marvel's cosmic threats in fact
he was actually part of the annihilators
now beta ray bill has super human
physical attributes including strength
speed and durability in terms of
strength bill is every bit the equal of
thor and a battle between the two of
them levels the surrounding countryside
on another occasion bill and thor work
together to hold up the entirety of
asgard which is basically like holding
up a planet now betty ray bill is also
an incredibly fast character possessing
the ability to travel faster than the
speed of light and on one occasion he
was able to escape a black hole due to
his insane speed now as for his
durability beta ray bill is pretty much
invulnerable to harm he's had planets
destroyed around him and barely even
seemed to notice he's taken energy
blasts from galactus and has even
survived being inside the hottest part
of a star so yeah i mean it's pretty
much impossible to kill beta ray bill
which is why he's routinely able to go
toe-to-toe with some of the most
powerful characters in marvel comics the
funny thing about this is bill is made
even more formidable by wielding his
hammer's stormbreaker which is one of
the most powerful weapons in marvel
comics as it's pretty much identical in
terms of power and enchantment to thor's
hammer mjolnir now while wielding
stormbreaker bill was able to cut
through one of galactus energy blasts
and was even able to crack galactus
armor which if you know anything about
galactus you know he is without a doubt
one of the strongest characters in the
history of marvel comics and that
harming him through conventional means
is nearly impossible but another ability
stormbreaker affords beta ray bill is
that he can create portals by spinning
the hammer at great speeds and these
portals allow him to transport himself
anywhere in the universe now when
coupled with his amazing strength bill
can use this ability to do some pretty
impressive things like bringing an
asteroid through one of the portals to
use in a battle against the ego of the
living planet and that fight was amazing
teleporting a black hole through one of
the portals or even teleporting the
entirety of asgard now stormbreaker can
also manipulate the weather and has the
specific ability of being able to
control lightning now it can also create
incredibly powerful force fields capable
of deflecting blows from the likes of
nova and super scroll whose powers are
basically designed to replicate those of
the fantastic four meaning his blast
should have been as strong as that of
the human torch now stormbreaker is also
capable of producing magical
enchantments manipulating the laws of
physics and sapping energy from its
opponents even ones as powerful as ego
furthermore vader ray bill is an expert
in hand-to-hand combat as well as an
expert battle strategist and tactician
so much so that thor has enough
confidence in his abilities that he
leads asgard under bill's command when
he himself is unable to lead and
although often overlooked as one of
marvel's most powerful characters beta
ray bill has more than enough feats to
justify himself as a beyond omega level
character for instance he's battled and
defeated stardust a herald of galactus
who's imbued with the power cosmic and
therefore roughly equivalent to the
silver surfer in terms of power speaking
of the silver surfer bills also battled
him and held his own until the surfer's
board basically incapacitated him by
hitting him in the back of the head
which is kind of a cheap shot but vader
ray bill has also proven himself to be
able to destroy planets with
stormbreaker on more than one occasion
and when he removes the restraints on
his power bill reaches a state only
sustainable for a few minutes but during
that time he's able to take out an
entire army that even stardust and
silver surfer combined could not handle
and when we remind ourselves that vader
ray bill was able to harm galactus it
leaves us with no doubt that horse thor
is absolutely beyond omega level and
should really get a lot more respect as
one of marvel's most powerful characters
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this to an end thank you
guys for watching and i will catch you
all later
peace